MALE SPEAKER: Well, good
afternoon to everybody here
in Mountain View.
Thanks for coming out.
To our Googlers tuning in
in offices around the world,
good day to you as well.
So we're in for a treat today.
The gentlemen to my right
probably need no introduction,
but I'll still venture to
try to give them one anyway.
The gentleman to
my immediate right
is none other than director
Kyle Patrick Alvarez.
He's LA-based.
He's a feature director,
writer, producer, and editor.
"The Stanford
Prison Experiment,"
which we're here to
talk about today,
marks his third
film as a director.
In 2010, he won the
Someone to Watch award
at the Independent Spirit Awards
for his directorial debut,
"Easier with Practice." "The
Stanford Prison Experiment"
was at this year's Sundance Film
Festival and the Nantucket Film
Festival, and I think it
won two awards at Sundance?
KYLE ALVAREZ: Yep.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
Very cool, exciting stuff.
And the gentleman
to my further right
is Philip G. Zimbardo, PhD,
AKA Dr. Z, Dr. Zimbardo.
He's one of the most
distinguished living
psychologists, having served
as president of the American
Psychological
Association, designed
and narrated the
award-winning 26-part PBS
series, "Discovering
Psychology," which
hooked me into psychology
as a high school student,
and has published more
than 50 books and 400
professional and popular
articles and chapters.
Among them, "Shyness," "The
Lucifer Effect," "The Time
Cure," and "The Time Paradox."
He's a bit of a Talks
at Google veteran,
so we're excited to
have him back here.
He's a professor emeritus
at Stanford University.
He spent 50 years teaching
and studying psychology,
received his PhD in psych
from Yale University,
and his areas of focus include
time perspective, shyness,
terrorism, madness, and evil.
KYLE ALVAREZ: I'm really
glad you introduced me first.
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER: They gave
me a lot more to say here.
We'll close it up.
We'll wrap it up.
Best known for his controversial
Stanford Prison Experiment
that highlighted
the ease with which
ordinary intelligent
college students could cross
the line between
good and evil when
caught up in the matrix of
situational and systemic
forces.
We'll talk a little bit
of heroism later, which
is what he's got on his
shirt, but let's get started.
Just so you guys
know, I'll do some
Q&A. We've prepared for
the first half of the hour,
and then we've got a mic for
the audience to do Q&A as well.
So the first part,
I want to talk
to you, Dr. Zimbardo, and
kind of set the stage for us.
So your study-- SPE, Stanford
Prison Experiment 1971--
this is 10 years after
Milgram's study began in 1961.
What's going on at this time?
Why are studies like this
so popular back then?
PHILIP ZIMBARDO: Well,
I should first mention
an interesting coincidence.
Little Stanley Milgram
and little Phil Zimbardo
sat side by side in James
Monroe High School in the Bronx
in 1949, 1950.
And as kids, we were
talking about situations
that-- I grew up
in the South Bronx.
He grew up in the North Bronx.
In what way does where you
grow up make a difference?
And we concluded it
makes a big difference.
Now his study in 1963 at Yale
used adults, 20 to 50-year-old
men mostly, and he said
no college students,
no high school students.
And there was no selection
fact, just anybody who
answered living in New
Haven, Connecticut,
and they got $4 an hour
for a study on memory.
So that was a lie.
So the idea was that
he would recruit
young men, young and
middle-aged men, in what they
thought was a study to help
people improve their memory.
And the way they were going
to help is by hurting.
So there was another
participant who they didn't
realize was a confederate.
So the real subject
is the teacher.
The confederate is
the student, pupil.
And teacher gives
something to learn.
They get it right, you say good.
When they get it wrong,
you deliver punishment.
And the way you
deliver punishment
is by pressing a
button on a shock box.
The shock box has 30 switches.
Each starts with 15
volts, and each switch
increases by 15 volts.
The problem is that
the confederate
starts to make mistakes,
starts to dumb down,
gets shocked more and more.
And there's a point at
which the confederate begins
to scream and yell, I've
got a heart condition.
And everybody says, I don't--
in terms of the experiment,
I don't want to go on.
The experiment's in
a white lab coat,
so that's the
authority obedient.
And the experiment
simply says, I'm sorry.
You must continue, teacher.
The experiment requires
you to continue.
So in order to get out,
you had to say three times,
I quit, I quit, I quit.
Once or twice is not enough.
And when it gets to 300 volts,
the guy is screaming and out
of control, and everybody
says, I don't want to go on.
So everybody verbally complains.
Everybody verbally
denies wanting to go on.
The problem is, what do they do?
Two out of every three
of the 1,000 subjects
goes all the way to 450 volts.
At that point, the
guy is unconscious.
He could be dead.
So it really shocked the
nation, shocked the world.
And the reason I
did my study-- then
I'll get back to answering
what was happening in
that time period-- is it's
rare that somebody says,
do bad shit.
You're in a group, and
everybody's doing bad shit.
You're in a
corporation, and people
begin to cheat and lie
and steal and get corrupt.
Or you play a role.
You're a manager.
Your role is you're the bully.
You're the traditional husband.
So what we want to
see, what happens
when you're in a situation where
situational forces push you
in a negative direction,
and nobody says
you should do good or do bad?
There was something
about the '60s and '70s,
which for me, I miss, because
it was a time of revolution.
It was a time of questioning.
People are-- so it's civil
rights are happening.
Anti-war activities
are happening, really
the start of feminism.
So it was really a
time, a very, for me,
a very exciting, exciting
period of social change.
And so I think Milgram
tied into that.
Now I must say he was a little
Jewish kid, meaning in 1948,
he was concerned, could the
Holocaust happen again here?
Could he and his family end
up in a concentration camp?
We said, Stanley,
don't be stupid.
That's Nazi Germany.
We're Americans.
We're not that kind of people.
And I still remember
him saying, I'll
bet they said the same thing
before the Nazis recruited
them to be in the SS.
And it could happen here.
MALE SPEAKER: I see that.
Thank you for the context.
So in the film and
also in interviews,
you've said that you had no idea
what to expect from your study.
So based on Milgram,
did you not have
an inkling that what
happened might have happened
or that folks would respond
to the authority in the way
that they did?
PHILIP ZIMBARDO: Well,
in Milgram's thing,
it's really a one-on-one
confrontation.
Somebody says, do bad shit,
you do it or you don't.
In our thing, we're not telling
them to do anything bad.
If we say, be a guard, well, in
your mind, you've seen movies.
You've seen "Cool Hand Luke."
You've seen "Heat of the Night."
You've seen other movies--
that guards had power.
So essentially, we assume that
there would be verbal abuse,
and the question is,
how long would it take?
Again, nobody wanted
to be a guard,
as you'll see in the
film, because guards
were like a policeman
who, in the '70s,
were called on college campuses
to break up anti-war rallies.
So cops-- police and cops
were pigs, oink, oink,
in those days.
And so essentially,
it's that in our study,
it was difficult for the kids
to get in the role of guards.
They put on military uniforms,
which felt awkward at first.
And you'll see
the opening scene.
The audience laughs
at the opening scene.
They didn't want
to be in that role.
And it took one day
before everything changed
as you saw in the
movie, and Kyle
will talk about that
transformation on day two.
MALE SPEAKER: I see.
OK.
And not to give too
much away from the film.
A lot of us were
there last night.
We had a screening just down the
street, but two quick questions
there.
One, in the film, as you're
sitting in one of the hallways,
I guess one of your
colleagues come,
and he kind of confronts
you, and he says,
what's your independent
variable in this study?
Would you answer
that for us now?
PHILIP ZIMBARDO: Yeah.
So in every experiment, there's
something you vary, manipulate,
and there's something
you measure.
When you do a correlational
study, you measure two things.
So I want to know,
are extroverts
more open to new
experience than introverts?
So I give scale-- extroversion,
openness experiment-- and I
do a correlation to say,
do they go together?
In experiments, the
thing you want to see
is, does behavior change?
And that's called the
dependent variable.
It's dependent on
what you manipulate,
and what you
manipulate is called
the independent
variable, just the terms.
So in this case,
the manipulation
was random assignment of
a group of 24 students
have to be guards and
have to be prisoners.
In the movie, they do their
thing of flipping a coin,
but in fact, there's a
table of random numbers
that you give
everybody a number.
Then pick out the number--
person to person I call it.
So the reason you do that is
at the beginning of the study,
there should be no
systematic difference
on any dimension
between prisoners
and the guard in
height, in weight,
in emotional
background, et cetera.
MALE SPEAKER: Wonderful.
Thank you.
And then the last
thing here, just
to set the context, what are
the results of the study?
If people don't know,
what did you learn?
What did you take away?
PHILIP ZIMBARDO: Yeah.
What's interesting
about the study,
it's been called infamous,
controversial, et cetera,
et cetera.
That's after the fact.
In 1971, Stanford
University had one
of the very first human
subject research committees
that I submitted a study to.
And every student filled
out an informed consent
to say, I will be an experiment
in which there'll be high
stress, there'll be minimally
adequate diet, et cetera,
et cetera.
I can leave the experiment-- I
can terminate my participation
simply by saying, I quit
the experiment or something
like that.
For me, that's a magical phrase.
They had to use those words,
"I quit the experiment."
If you say, "I want
out," that wasn't good.
And so they filled
out that form.
The problem was before
you knew the results,
it was kids playing
cops and robbers
in the basement of
Stanford University.
What could happen?
Nothing.
If anything, what
they said was, you've
been summoned to the committee.
You needed to have a fire
extinguisher, because there
was only one entrance.
There's no windows,
so if there was
a fire-- you'll see the movie,
as happened in this thing,
they used the fire extinguisher
against the prisoners.
So in hindsight you say,
wow, it's really unethical.
People suffered.
How could anybody allow this?
They couldn't imagine,
as I couldn't, what
happened in two days.
And it's not clear in the movie,
but at the end of day one,
I told my graduate students and
my team, if nothing changed,
we're going to end this.
And nothing's happening.
It's so awkward.
It's embarrassing to sit there.
And then day two, the
prisoners revolt, and suddenly,
everything changes.
MALE SPEAKER: Wonderful.
Thank you.
This is for both of
you, either of you.
So how'd you get
involved in the project?
Why this film?
Why this time?
Talk to us about
how that happened.
KYLE ALVAREZ: Well, for
me, and then we can--
I'll backtrack a little bit
then with Dr. Zimbardo's
initial involvement.
The script-- or you can
chime in at any point.
I guess the
project-- pretty much
since the experiment
happened, someone
has been trying to
do a film out of it.
And you know, there's
been various iterations.
There was the writer of
"In the Heat of the Night,"
met you, brought you
down to Los Angeles.
This is back in the '70s.
There was another
version at some point.
Then there was a
version in the '90s
that Leonardo DiCaprio
was going to do
before "Titanic" happened.
It was going to be him
and Benicio Del Toro.
And then it led to
this version happening,
and there was this
producer who's
from the Bay Area
named Brent Emery,
and he reached out to you.
And he--
PHILIP ZIMBARDO: Took an option.
KYLE ALVAREZ: Yeah, took
an option on the rights
to the story and
pieced together--
they got Chris
McQuarrie involved,
who has a movie coming out
in two weeks, the new Mission
Impossible movie.
And he brought in a guy he
writes with sometimes named Tim
Talbottt.
So Tim started writing the
script at the same time
then that Phil was writing
"The Lucifer Effect."
And so they were always
in touch with each other,
sharing the research, sharing
the documents, everything.
It was sort of like a
perfect little storm for Tim
to write this script.
And the first thing he did
was throw everything in there.
He's like, let's just start.
I've read it.
It's like a 300-something page,
whatever, 280-page script,
and it starts with, waking up on
the morning of the experiment,
and he put in every detail.
And then, really, I think
the writing of it for Tim
and what Tim did so well was,
OK, what do you pull out,
and in effort then,
who are the people
we follow in the experiment?
Where is the structure?
And it really became an
act of structuring a story
around a lot of characters.
And then the
project got cast up.
It had what was not a star--
probably equivalent to the cast
we have now.
It was like Ryan Philippe
and Jesse Eisenberg
and Giovanni Ribisi and
Channing Tatum at the time.
PHILIP ZIMBARDO: This was just
before they became famous.
I went down and met
with all these guys,
and they all have become
famous young actors.
KYLE ALVAREZ: Yeah, and
it was 13 years ago.
PHILIP ZIMBARDO: He
couldn't raise the money.
KYLE ALVAREZ: Yeah.
They were trying to make it
a much bigger budget film.
It was a different time.
Independent film was in
a very different time.
I mean I was just going
into college at the time
and remember reading
about the project,
and it didn't come
together as hundreds--
I mean in the time
I've been talking,
five movies have
died in Hollywood.
You know, they have
the billboards,
how many people have died
from smoking this year.
You can do the same with
the Hollywood projects.
And it didn't happen, but the
script was so well-appreciated
that the word of the script
kind of always lingered around,
or you read these articles of
the great unproduced scripts,
and it was always on there.
And Brent always held onto
the rights, the producer
I mentioned earlier.
And this actor
from my first film,
Brian Garrity, who's one of
the stars of "The Hurt Locker"
and a bunch of other films,
he had auditioned-- probably
had auditioned for the
film 10 years earlier,
13 years earlier.
And he was friends
with Brent, and they
were talking one night.
And Brent-- long story short,
long story long-- Brent
was like, oh, yeah.
I'm still trying to get the
Stanford Prison Experiment
movie made, and Brian was
like, oh, you should send it
to my friend, Kyle.
And some of the point
of that whole story
is that it really, like
sometimes these things
or here's this project that
people have been laboring over
for 40 years, and
it just came down
to like two guys sharing a
drink and someone being like,
oh, I should send
that to my friend.
And then I read the
script and started
to really read about the
experiment, learn about it,
realize that the script
had stayed so true to what
the experiment was,
and from there, got
involved with the project.
This was a few years ago.
And since then, I took
a little time away
to make the film I made before.
But it's really been--
for Hollywood terms,
it went by-- three years for
a film to get made is short.
I hate to say that, but it is
a really short period of time.
MALE SPEAKER: I see.
So this is a question that
came up a little while ago
in discussion, and the question
was, why not a documentary?
Why a drama?
And is it because you
inherited the project
after it was already
written as a drama, or?
KYLE ALVAREZ: No,
because I get sent
scripts or biopics of people's
lives or books all the time.
And I think when it's
something that's contemporary,
i.e. there's video of it, and
there's interviews of the time,
and there's books been
written-- we're not
talking about something that's
totally undocumented-- you say,
OK, well, why do this?
Why do you need to
do this as a film?
I think a lot of
people make movies,
and the rationale is based
on true people or biopics
or situations, and
the rationale is,
well, it just hasn't
been a movie yet,
so you've got to do it.
And that's not enough
for me, and so when
I looked at the documentary, the
"Quiet Rage", the documentary
that Dr. Zimbardo made
about the experiment,
and I read the book,
I felt that they
had done such a good
job encompassing
the studious nature
of the experiment.
But what those couldn't do,
and they wouldn't be able to,
they wouldn't be as good
as a material as they are
is try to create the more
experiential or the more
emotional-- something that an
actor can bring to the film.
And so you watch the footage,
and just like in the film,
it's just one camera at the end.
And it was very expensive
to run video in 1971,
so there is quite a lot of
footage, but not everything.
There's a lot of
audio recordings.
It just felt like there
was this opportunity
to literally get
inside of that space
and hopefully maybe
illuminate some
of the that emotional
capacity, the emotional effect
this experiment had on people.
MALE SPEAKER: I see.
So how'd you do the casting?
How'd you cast Dr.
Z. and all the?
KYLE ALVAREZ: We started
with the kids, actually.
So it's 25 leads, which is
really unusual for a low budget
movie.
It's unusual for any movie.
And I saw them all as leads.
I didn't want to say, oh,
well, that guy doesn't really
do much, so he's not-- we'll
just get central casting.
I wanted it to be
each person, you
could train the camera
on them, and the scene
could become about them.
And it took a long time.
We were casting as
we were financing,
so I basically started just
meeting with these guys.
I had a list of people I knew
I wanted to be in the movie,
and I started meeting with
them trying to figure out
their temperaments.
Young actors can be
really, really volatile
in a really great way.
They can be those guys
that just want to dive in
and be really methody
and want to like only
be called the character's name.
And there's so much
ambition there,
and it's a really great
thing, and it's a really great
if you're making a movie
where you can give them
all the attention and comforts
and things that come along
with that.
But when you've got
25 of them around,
there's no time for that.
So really, I was vetting them.
I guess I was doing
psychological vetting on them
to see how they would be.
So the hotshot kid who comes
in and sits at lunch and goes,
yeah-- he like unwraps
his cigarettes out
of a pack in his pocket, and
he's like, I studied Meisner,
and I did all
this, and these are
the techniques I like to use.
You'd say, that's not the
guy that's going to work.
He's incredibly talented.
And then we started
doing auditions,
and we got some of
the guys in the bigger
parts involved initially.
And then as we were
making the film,
trying to cast the
Zimbardo part, it's tough.
You want someone who
can evoke that feeling,
but you're not
trying to do mimicry,
but you want it to
also-- as much as we're
recreating the experiment, try
to match that kind of feeling.
And I've just always
loved Billy Crudup.
He's always been
one of my favorites.
I think he's underutilized.
I think he's underappreciated,
and he's just
incredibly talented.
And fortunately, I
had just made a movie
with Corey Stoll-- it's
so weird to see him.
He's in "Ant Man" on the same
weekend blowing things up
and the CG stuff.
But Corey had just
done a movie with Billy
and had told Billy that he
really liked working with me.
So when the script came around
to Billy with my name on it,
he was interested.
But the interesting thing
connected to what you just said
was when I first
sat down with Billy,
his hesitation was-- he said,
well, I just don't understand.
How did they not know
this was going to happen?
And that was his big thing that
was holding him back from maybe
saying yes to the project.
And I remember it like
an 8:00 AM meeting,
because he had a plane to catch.
And I was like tired.
And in one of those weird
moments where it dings, and I
was like, he didn't know
it was going to happen,
because the Stanford Prison
Experiment hadn't happened yet.
This was the thing
that defined it.
That's where it's not naivety.
There was no point of reference.
And I think that
was the thing that
sort of got Billy on board.
And he's just one of those
guys, if you can work with him,
it's like a highlight.
And I was really glad
he did the movie.
And I was really glad all
these guys-- Ezra Miller,
the first time I met
on the film, I said,
if we don't make this
movie with Ezra Miller,
we're making a mistake.
He walked from 1971 into 2015.
It's bizarre.
He's not of this era, and when
we put this cast together,
our dream was to build a cast
like "The Outsiders," one
of these from "Dazed and
Confused," where you look back
10 years, and we
would always say
that you look back 10
years, and you're not
going to believe all these
guys were in the same movie.
And really it's
been like 10 months.
We didn't know Ezra was
going to be the Flash and now
one of the new leads in
the Harry Potter spinoff,
and Tye Sheridan as
Cyclops, and Ki Hong Li
has "The Maze Runner."
All these guys,
these were all things
that happened after
we made the film.
And part of that's engineered,
part of that's luck,
and part of that's--
I don't know.
Part of that's
mojo or something.
And so it was really a privilege
and like an embarrassment
of riches to get to work
with all of these guys.
PHILIP ZIMBARDO: You also said
you had them read both prison
and guard parts.
KYLE ALVAREZ: Yeah, when we have
people come and audition when
we did the more not
open casting calls,
but we'd bring actors
in, for the most part,
unless I had something specific
in mind, but most of the times,
we just said-- we wrote scenes.
So I would combine
some of the characters
and just put some of the
highlights of moments
that they needed to see.
And we just said to them,
you can come and read one,
you can read the other,
you can read both.
And it was an interesting
thing, and in some cases,
I would cast them
against the part
they thought they should play.
Some cases, they just
did what they did.
They knew themselves,
so it was a weird thing.
In a lot of cases,
it was really fun
to try to take some of these
kids, who-- a lot of them
were from Disney shows and
Nickelodeon shows, and this was
sort of their first more
serious feature-- and be like,
oh, no, you're
going to be a guard.
You're like, well, I was
Hannah Montana's best friend.
But then that's fun for them,
because they don't-- I remember
James Wolk, who plays
one of the grad students,
was just so happy to be in a
costume and to have facial hair
and a wig.
He just wanted that,
because he's always
playing the handsome boyfriend.
He was thrilled.
It's one of these
things where you're
giving these guys opportunities
to do something a little bit
different, and they
just chew it up.
MALE SPEAKER: I see.
Now obviously, Dr. Zimbardo's
involved in the process.
Were any of the
original subjects
involved in the
filming or not at all?
KYLE ALVAREZ: No.
It was a careful and
deliberate choice for me.
Part of it was that
I felt what they
would contribute to it, that
research had already been done.
He had done extensive
followup interviews.
There's also interviews
leading all the way up
to just like maybe 10 years ago
last that you could see online.
But while I felt we were
representing Dr. Zimbardo
directly and his wife, Dr.
Christina Maslach, or Christina
Zimbardo, directly, I
felt that everyone else,
it would do a
disservice if I was
trying to cast someone that
looked like this person.
We weren't learning about them.
The only people we learn about
outside the experiment is him.
And so for me, it felt like
when we changed all their names,
not even for legal reasons.
We changed them,
because I didn't feel--
I met a woman the other day.
She goes, my brother
was one of the guards.
My brother was John Mark.
And I go, I couldn't even tell
you who played him in the film.
Because in order to reduce it
down into a two-hour movie,
we were combining certain
things people did.
So these characters
were being defined
by the actions they took
inside of the experiment,
and I felt if I even connected
the actors to the real people,
it just would've created
this cacophony of-- it
just felt like we
weren't actually making
a movie about those individuals.
We were making a movie
about the actions they took.
And you know, it's
a tricky decision,
because you don't want
to make a movie then
where someone goes
and sees it and says,
it was nothing like that.
I wish you would've
touched base with me,
and I could've told you
this, this, and this.
But when there's so
many, it would've
been-- I think it would
have been an endless pit.
MALE SPEAKER: I understand.
PHILIP ZIMBARDO:
And the other thing
is a number of the
prisoners and a number
of the guards to this day
said, I was just acting.
I was just acting.
It wasn't the situation factor.
I just chose to be a
prisoner who broke down.
They just chose
to be evil guard.
And I tell them, I say,
wow, that's really great.
I don't know any
professional actor
who could stay in part eight
hours a day day after day,
day after day, day after day.
So I think they were right.
They started playing a
role, especially the guy who
plays John Wayne.
In the movie it's
played brilliantly.
He was an 18-year-old
college freshman
at Whitman College
interested in drama,
and he saw the movie
"Cool Hand Luke" recently,
and he just chose to
be Strother Martin.
And it was a conscious
choice on his part,
but the point is you'll see
once he gets into the role,
he becomes evil.
In fact, it's the
definition of creative evil.
Then he's stuck in
that role, and he's
the one who says-- now
the guards work eight hour
shifts so that they were home
doing the usual things-- some
are madder than others.
And he's the one that
says, you come in,
you put on your guard
uniform, you put on silver
reflecting sunglasses I got
from the movie "Cool Hand Luke,"
you get the billy club,
you step out on the yard,
and you are a guard.
This is what he said later.
And then he said in a
recent-- after Abu Ghraib,
our prison study got infamous
again, and he was interviewed.
And he said, given
a little more time,
we guards could have
got where they were.
And he said, we were just
getting off our jollies
by being puppeteers, and the
prisoners were our puppets.
This is 30 years later.
That is not acting.
That is taking the
mentality he created
44 years ago into the present.
KYLE ALVAREZ: Well,
what that says
to me is that there is power
in what we call acting.
That's what I talked to the
actors a lot about this.
I was like, you're
professional role players
playing unprofessional role
players in this experiment.
So you need to stay the
professional role player.
That was the thing, and
that's why it was actually
a really fun and pleasant set,
especially when we were working
with the kids, because they
were constantly aware of that.
But I think-- I'm
mostly certain it's
a Vonnegut quote, which
is embarrassing, because I
have a Vonnegut tattoo.
But he said, be careful
who you pretend to be,
because you become
what you pretend to be.
And I do think that that to me
was a really interesting thing
to see actors do.
I wasn't trying to
make a movie that
was super aware of
its meta quality,
but there is
something that is-- it
would be interesting for someone
who is in the acting world
or writes papers about
the acting theories
to write, OK, where is it?
You hear these stories of
actors who get lost in parts
or whatever it might be, and
it's really hard for them
to return to their lives
and their family lives,
and I think it's a really
similar extension of what
was going on there, where it
does start as fun and games,
and at a certain point, if
you're really good at it,
if you access yourself,
you lie to yourself enough,
and so our goal in making the
film was to not get that far,
to get that far when
the camera's rolling,
and then you shut it off.
MALE SPEAKER: Did you
have any close calls?
KYLE ALVAREZ: No.
We did when Chris is doing
the pushups at the end.
He was just like,
look, let's just do it.
So he was really
doing the pushups.
Jack and Logan were really
sitting on his back.
And he was like, I can
give you like three takes.
Fortunately, he was probably
the strongest guy in the cast.
PHILIP ZIMBARDO: Physically.
KYLE ALVAREZ: Physically, yeah,
but I had asked all the actors
to stop working out,
because I didn't
want them to be-- there were a
few scenes we shot that weren't
in the film where they had to
bathe before the visitors come.
And people in the
'70s didn't have--
that was Matt Weiner's
rule for his actors
weren't-- that's what
they always said.
The actors weren't allowed
to go to the gym who
were on "Mad Men," because
that's not how people looked.
And these actors only
had two weeks notice.
We had no rehearsal period
or anything, so by the time
he got to lunch,
we got to lunch.
It was steak kebabs
were what's for lunch,
and Chris's arms were
like he couldn't do it.
I had to take the steak off
for him, and you feel bad.
But even then, it was like
he was invigorated by it.
There was never a time
where-- these actors
were actually having fun.
I have like dozens of
videos on my phone of when
we were shooting the raid stuff,
and Nick Braun, the really tall
guy, has Ezra against the wall.
In between takes where we're
all moving the camera, just
to keep their energy up, they
would just like play wrestle.
They were just having a blast.
For them, that's fun.
That's what they were there.
That's what they love.
PHILIP ZIMBARDO:
Yeah, but the scene
is where the evil
John Wayne guard has
him doing pushups and then
literally stepping on his back,
pushing him down, and
then has two prisoners
sit on him while he's
still doing the pushups.
And that really
happened in the study,
but it was amazing that
he could even do one.
He had two people
sitting on him.
KYLE ALVAREZ: And it was
interesting-- speaking
of the moments where it
does, this just popped
into my-- Chris is struggling
and probably legitimately
starting to tear up.
And he falls, and the
producers are on my case,
because we're a union
project, and we're already
in grace period and lunch.
I'm like, we need to go in.
I'm like, this guy is literally
killing himself for us.
We need to not cut him off.
And Michael at the
end of the take
throws him back up
against the wall,
and he's like, you can't
even do one lousy pushup.
And it was totally
made the line up.
And I was like, that's
the most-- he made it up
right there, didn't
even think about it.
He doesn't remember
really saying it.
And I was like, that is the
cruelest thing I've ever heard.
But it came from his character,
and it really wasn't to him.
There was still that line.
But we didn't get it on
camera, so they were like,
we've got to break
for lunch, and I was
like, I have to get that line.
I was like, there's no way I'm
not going to shoot that line.
They were like
calling for lunch.
I think people, the grips
were like, fuck this.
And they're walking out
and everything like that,
and it was just-- but you don't
have to-- it's a weird thing,
because I like to
follow the rules.
And a lot of the
great filmmakers
don't follow the rules,
but the thing I always do
try to remind myself,
and it's really
hard in a movie like this
where there's so little time,
but I worked for Warren
Beatty for awhile,
and he's infamous for
doing hundreds of takes.
I've never done more
than five takes.
This film, we never did
more than two or three.
There was no time to.
But one time I was like,
why do you do so many takes?
And he goes, well, because
everything that costs money
here-- like the sets, the
food, getting the actors here,
the locations-- he's
like, the thing that
costs the least amount of money
is the film and the camera,
in this case, the hard
drive and the camera.
That's the cheapest
thing there, so why
aren't you going to
always keep on running?
And there's a
modified truth to that
that you can harness
without doing 100 takes.
PHILIP ZIMBARDO: How long
did the prisoner guard takes?
Was it two weeks?
KYLE ALVAREZ:
Yeah, we were there
two and 1/2 weeks
in that hallway,
and then we had a week and
1/2 in another building where
all the outside stuff was.
MALE SPEAKER: Very cool.
Well, not to interrupt
the mojo here,
but we had a screening
last night, and about 10
of us in a group went together.
There was 100 of us, but
10 of us in the group
that I was with.
And I remember the movie ends,
the credits roll, and there's
just radio silence from all my
friends and I for quite awhile.
And it's been awhile since
we've been to a movie
where every one of my friends
and I were just blown away,
everybody two thumbs up,
rave reviews, loved it.
Now first thing that
came to use as we're
talking through it is about half
of us were like, you know what?
I bet you it was that intense.
I bet you they didn't
take too many liberties.
I'll bet you that's
what it was like.
And half the folks were
like, I don't know, man.
There's some stuff,
some of the stuff there,
I don't know if I
could have taken it.
So we're curious--
PHILIP ZIMBARDO: I could've
taken it if I was there?
KYLE ALVAREZ: No, they're
saying what in the film
was made up or exaggerated.
MALE SPEAKER: Precisely, yeah.
KYLE ALVAREZ: I mean, he
could speak a little more.
I'll let him speak literally--
well, say that first,
and I'll say my two cents on it.
PHILIP ZIMBARDO: I mean, so
they've compressed six days
into two hours.
Now if anything, there were
a lot of dramatic things
that happened in the real
study that got deleted,
or they couldn't put
in because of budget.
So there's nothing in the film,
none of the dramatic events
in the film were made up.
They will mimicked
what really happened.
The last scene I
think puts together
three things that happened
separated by more hours.
And so the last scene is
riveting, overwhelming,
emotionally distressing,
and I worried
the first time I saw that.
I said, people are going to
walk out of here in tears
and say, I'm through with this.
I didn't pay 12 bucks to--
but the goal is, how do you
transform that
emotional distress
to intellectual self-analysis?
What kind of guard
would I have been?
What kind of prisoner?
If I was the Zimbardo
character, wouldn't I
have ended it sooner?
Should he have run
it for two weeks?
And then if this is a
simulated prison, what must
it be like to be
in a real prison
where guards have guns
and power over you,
and there are gangs, among
the prisoners there are gangs.
So our prison is really more
like a prisoner of war camp,
because everybody comes
in at the same time.
If you go to a prison,
there's a prison hierarchy.
There's guys who have
been there 30 years.
There's the really bad guys.
There's gangs.
There's black, Hispanic,
skinhead, white gangs,
and again, if you're in
prison and you're a young guy,
and you don't have
a gang connection,
you're going to be a sissy.
The only question is how long.
So there's a whole
dynamic, which
I know operates in
a system-- I studied
prison-- which we didn't have.
So in a funny way, it's
like everybody starts
in a prisoner of war camp,
so nobody has a history.
And the curious thing is
that everyone got trapped
in the expanded moment.
We bug the cells, and 90%
of all the conversation
was about the prison, the
food, the guards, escape.
That means they knew
nothing about each other.
They knew they're
all college students.
They didn't say, what
school do you go to?
What are you majoring in?
And nothing about
their future-- what
are you going to do when you
get out, because all of them
are going to start-- it's
the end of summer school.
They're all going to start
in September in college.
And I should mention
only two students were
Stanford students-- one guard
and one prisoner-- because we
did it in the summer,
and kids are finishing up
summer school at Berkeley, at
Stanford, and other places.
The movie, it mentions
Stanford three times,
so some people believe that
they were all Stanford students.
That is done in the basement
of Jordan Hall at Stanford,
but it's universal for college
students, white college
students mostly.
KYLE ALVAREZ: And my
feeling, too, we obviously,
we stayed very
true-- I mean I have
sort of like three-pronged
thing to that.
One is the idea of
saying something
is based a true story
means nothing anymore.
I mean, I remember
when I read the script,
there was a movie
around that time,
maybe it was last year or
something or two years ago.
There was a movie
with Eric Bana where
he's like a cop fighting
demons in New York,
and it was based on
the true accounts of--
and it's not based
on a true story.
Maybe this guy
says that happened,
but we know there aren't
demons in New York.
And so it really started
with "The Exorcist," I think.
And that's not a
slam on that movie,
but that started with that
idea of the lure, the fear,
so now when we go see "The
Conjuring," it's like,
"In the summer of,"
that kind of thing.
And for me, I sort
of felt-- but then
we look at our really
historical films
like "Lincoln" brazenly
makes stuff up.
It changes public voting record.
At the end of the film
when they're voting,
it just made it up
for more tension.
So that's something that-- and
I feel-- and that's not even
a slam on that movie.
But for me, I felt like
when you look at that,
to say our film is, I think
fair when you say about 90%
accurate, I think is an
overwhelming number when
the movies we look at
or consider historical
probably live more in
the 30%, in many cases
maybe the 10% or something.
So we set our
threshold much higher.
Now having said that,
I do think people
who are-- in terms
of a lot of the words
and the dialogue is
coming from that,
I suspect, and I haven't
talked to anybody
who was in the
experiment, I suspect
they might say something like,
it really wasn't that bad.
You watch the footage, and
it doesn't seem that bad,
but that's where what I was
doing wasn't exaggerating it.
I was saying, OK, well, I'm
telling you to look at this.
You start to question, what's
your job as a filmmaker, not
a documentarian, but a filmmaker
is to create an emotion.
So I'm putting music in.
I'm putting cuts in.
I'm putting close-ups in.
I'm doing all
these things that--
PHILIP ZIMBARDO: Slo-mo.
KYLE ALVAREZ: Slow motion,
I'm doing then performance.
So you're doing things that
say, we're evoking this emotion.
It's not about trying to
Hollywoodize it or create
something like that.
It's just trying to say, this is
the story we're trying to tell.
So to me, if someone
came-- maybe someone will
come forward and be like, oh,
my god, it was exactly the same.
And that'd be really
enriching to hear,
but at the same-- or
maybe horrifying--
but at the same time, if
someone came forward and wrote
something, it was
nothing like that,
and it's Hollywood
doing-- I'd be like,
well, you have the
right to feel that way,
but we also have the right to
say, OK, here's this close-up,
and here's this
performance, and here's
the music, and all the things
that-- it becomes fiction.
As soon as you put a camera
in front of something,
as soon as you put a
cut into something,
it becomes fiction in a way.
And I mean that speaking
of narrative filmmaking.
That's a totally
different conversation
than documentary
filmmaking, but even then,
nowadays documentary
filmmaking, especially the trend
lately has become very
blurry with fiction.
That's now just
totally different.
MALE SPEAKER: I understand.
So speaking of emotion
and invoking emotion,
so what I appreciated
most about the film
was not particularly
just the moments
where things get really
tense, or sometimes there's
physical force used.
For me, it was when folks
decide that they're out,
when some of the prisoners
decide, I'm done with this.
And they start
trying to find a way
to scheme a way out of this.
I felt by the end of the film
like I was in this theater,
and there were times
when I wanted out, just
like the prisoners.
And it was so power--
not from the film,
but I felt the prisoners
is what I'm saying.
What I'm curious about
is, what was the contract?
Were they able to get out?
Was it paramount to keep them
involved as long as possible?
And I'm saying
it's a compliment.
I think you guys did
an incredible job
of making you feel like the
kids who were in the cell.
KYLE ALVAREZ: What's interesting
on a filmmaking set, and I
think the actual contract
is an interesting thing
to talk about, was
that I started to--
before the movie premier,
we shot it in October,
premiered it in January, so it
was a really fast turnaround.
And at the premiere-- we
premiered it at Sundance,
and it went from
12 people having
seen this movie to
two hours later,
1,300 people have
now seen this movie.
And so it's an
overwhelming feeling,
and it was weird,
because I was working
so hard through the film to
make it brutal by the end,
but not, so the first
hour of the film, I think,
has moments of levity.
There's a lot of humor.
I really was telling the cast
and working on the script
to really make sure it wasn't--
if it was harrowing 10 minutes
in, you were fucked for the
next hour and 50 minutes.
Sorry.
And so for me, it was about
trying to earn that ending
and for it to crescendo
to that as opposed
to being one of
these movies that's
just trying to brutalize you.
But because then,
even in the editing,
for instance it's 10 minutes
the big final sequence,
and the first cut of the
film, it was 30 minutes.
And it wasn't a fat 30 minutes.
It was a lot more
stuff happened.
And so we were
trimming away to say,
well, we don't want
to make a movie that's
so-- so when it was going
to premiere, my fear was
that people were going
to be like, ho hum,
we've seen this before.
Like who really cares?
And the first question
was out there like,
did you think you made an
experiment on the audience?
And I didn't understand
the question,
and I probably
gave a bad answer,
because I thought the
person was criticizing me.
But I realized what they were
saying was what you just said,
which was what we
did, and I think
we earned it through
the effort of not
trying to push people too far.
MALE SPEAKER: I see
what you're saying.
KYLE ALVAREZ: I think.
Well, maybe some people will
think we pushed too far,
but that's where it
really comes down
to a conversation about editing.
But it was weird,
because I didn't
anticipate that reaction.
I was so nervous at the reaction
being, oh, we've seen this.
But instead, it was people
were having that same feeling
of being hard to talk, and
that's what I wanted to achieve
but maybe had feared I hadn't
MALE SPEAKER: And just
really quick, just to--
PHILIP ZIMBARDO: And he
also is seeing it edited
while he's directing.
MALE SPEAKER: I see.
KYLE ALVAREZ: And then
you're editing it,
and you've been watching
it non-stop over and over.
I can't watch the movie anymore.
I poked my head in.
It opened in theaters
in LA last Friday
at the theater I go to
sometimes three times a week,
and so I was like,
I have to poke--
I've never seen any of my
own movies on this screen.
And I poked my head in, and
I was watching one scene,
and then I was like,
I should've done that.
There was a scene where
someone leaned back in a chair,
and I was like, how come
there's not a squeak there?
You start seeing those things,
and then you have to stop.
That's why you can't
watch the movie.
I think I read an
interview, I think
it was Alfonso Cuaron, who did
"Gravity," where he was like,
when I finish the
film, I watch it
at the premiere
with an audience,
and I never watch it again.
It's partly due to that.
It's partly due to I need to be
here and speak about the film,
hopefully in an engaging way,
and if I'm thinking about
the three frames I should've cut
between those shots, you can't.
And in addition to that, you
want to be able to move on.
I'm not one of those people--
I get really confused
by the filmmakers who go
back and re-cut their movies
years later.
I think there's something
kind of-- I find
something kind of sad about it.
Well, sometimes
the director's cut
is because the studios
give you an opportunity
to put your version out.
In this case, this is
enough of my version
that I wouldn't do it.
There's certainly
some things that
were contentious between me and
the producers and financiers,
but nothing I can't live
with at the end of the day.
So it being a representative
of the movie I wanted to make,
I think, well, I don't
want to go back-- yes,
of course, I'm going to
look back in 10 years
and be like, well, I should've
done a million things.
I look back in 10
months now, less even,
and want to change
a million things.
But it was representative
of the restrictions
I was under physically,
time, money,
and it was a representative
of who I was at 31,
and all of these other things.
And you don't want
to change that.
You just want to move on
and then make the next one
with what you learned.
MALE SPEAKER: I understand that.
And just to clarify, when I
mentioned being in the audience
and wanting to be like, wanting
to [INAUDIBLE], what I mean
is I'm starting to plot
with these prisoners.
I'm thinking, how
would I get out?
How would I get out?
KYLE ALVAREZ: I thought you
meant, is it OK if I leave?
MALE SPEAKER: No,
and I think you guys
captured that incredibly well.
So what was it like
for these prisoners?
How do they get out
if they wanted to?
PHILIP ZIMBARDO: There
was a magical formula
that the human subject
committee said.
All they had to say is,
I quit the experiment.
If you say, I want
out, I'm sorry.
I don't understand
that language.
If they say, I can't
take it, I'm sorry.
Wrong language.
So essentially, implicitly,
they are saying,
I quit the experiment.
But literally, if they used that
phrase, they would be released.
After day one, the word
"experiment" ceases to exist.
They say, I want out, write
a letter to the parole board.
So we had a parole board.
Now in the movie, we
only show one prisoner.
Every prisoner, except one
applied for the parole board,
and the parole board was
headed by an ex-convict,
brilliantly played,
who had just got out
of prison after 17 years,
who hated parole boards,
because they had turned
him down 16 years in a row.
And so he plays the role,
and he becomes his enemy.
And he says that
he literally got
sick-- he's a friend of
mine, Carlo Prescott--
got sick, because he did
this brilliant performance,
an improvisational performance,
not for the camera,
but for-- now again,
we had secretaries.
They show me and
the staff there.
It was not the case.
It was secretaries in a
different part of the building,
and the most dramatic thing
that happens at the end,
he said, OK, take him away.
Stand up, and then we ask,
if we were to parole you,
would you be willing to
forfeit all the money
you have earned as a prisoner?
Everyone says yes.
The only reason they're
there is for 15 bucks a day.
They just said, I
don't want your money.
What should they have done?
I'm out of here.
They take away.
They put their hands out.
Guards put their handcuffs, put
their bag, and take them away.
At that point,
they are prisoners.
It's not an experiment.
MALE SPEAKER: I see.
I want to turn it
over to the audience,
I have one more question about
this for you, Dr. Zimbardo.
Coming into the film, and having
done a little research on it
beforehand, I was really looking
for the moment, the turning
point where I guess
motivations get changed.
I was looking for the moment
where the guards cross
the line when people change.
You to talk about these being
smart, intelligent college
students.
When does that change happen?
And I noticed I think
twice in the film,
there's a moment where it
gets a little physical,
it gets a little violent.
There's also a moment where
somebody does try to get out.
And it seemed in those
moments that the guards
and your researchers,
everybody looked to you
and wanted to know what you
thought would happen next.
And in those moments
initially, before you obviously
canceled-- you called it
off six days in-- initially
you said, let's keep going.
Let's let it run.
Did you feel caught
up in the moment?
Did you feel like
your own motivations
were changed as well?
PHILIP ZIMBARDO:
There's no question.
I mean, the main
part of the study
is-- the most interesting
part of the study for me,
the takeaway message
is everybody's kids.
I'm an old guy.
I'm 36, I guess,
or 38 years old.
And I'm a seasoned researcher,
and I get caught up
in the system I created.
Again, it was by being the
principal investigator.
I should have stopped it at
after the second kid broke
down.
We proved our point.
But because I had in my mind
we want to go for two weeks,
and a prisoner breakdown, my
job as principal investigator
is get a replacement.
Get a replacement, and
taking the student out.
So I got trapped in
that role, and there's
a scene-- the real
transformation was
after visiting days, parents
had to see the superintendent.
So they came to my office
that said Superintendent.
And there's a scene where
I become something I hate.
I become a sexist, meaning
a mother and father come,
and the mother
says to me, I don't
mean to make trouble, sir.
Red light, bing.
Nobody says that unless
they're going to make trouble.
And she says, I've never seen
my son looking so terrible.
So at that moment--
I know she's going
to blow the whistle--
I immediately flip,
and I do what every
authority does.
I say, what seems to
be your son's problem?
So I'm making it
dispositional when we're
studying the situational force.
I know exactly what happened.
She said, well, he
hasn't been sleeping.
I said, does he have insomnia?
Again, what's wrong
with your kid?
She says, no, he told
me they wake them
up all hours of the night.
I said, oh, yes,
of course we do.
That's the counts.
Each guard shift has
to account for the fact
that prisoners have not escaped.
And then she says again, I
don't mean to make trouble.
What am I going to do?
Who's my cast?
There's the mother who's
going to make trouble,
and there's the father
who's been silent.
Both of them had just seen
their kid looking terrible.
I turn to the father.
What do I say?
Don't you think your son
is tough enough to take it?
At that moment, she's
a silly little woman,
and I think we probably
did this guy shake.
And he said, of course he is.
He's a real leader.
And at that moment, he
says, come on, honey,
and takes her away.
I felt so terrible because, I
realized what I had just done.
I had become, again,
a sexist guy seizing
the moment for what reason?
To save my prison, because
she was going to make trouble,
and she would've.
He broke down that night.
He's 819, had a
breakdown that night,
and she was exactly right.
And her husband, the
kid's father sold him out.
KYLE ALVAREZ: I remember
when we were shooting
that scene in the film that
day, I was sharing a building
downtown, and it
was Saturday night,
and so people started going out
to the clubs that were nearby.
So there was literally
like drunk people
banging on the doors
of the building
like, hey, what's going on?
What are you doing in there?
And Billy was trying to
work up the anger you're
talking about at this woman,
and I could hear him on the mic.
So before he would run takes,
he would say these things
to himself.
He'd be like, this
is my experience.
You're not taking
this away from me.
Who do you think you are?
You want me to say these things.
They were so great.
It so fascinating to hear how
you-- but you run those things.
You don't just think them,
but you say them out loud,
and then you kind of get that.
So he would sort of have that.
And nevertheless, then
there's drunk people
like banging on the windows that
just sort of like came alive.
PHILIP ZIMBARDO: So again,
forget about the kids.
So here's me getting
into the role.
Here's Carlo Prescott, a
seasoned criminal, a felon,
who, again, plays the role
of the parole board head
and becomes that.
And the third
character is there's
a scene where a Catholic priest
comes in and talks to the kids.
I taught a course on the
psychology of imprisonment
at Stanford in July with
Carlo Prescott in order
for me to learn about prisons.
And this priest heard
about that and came
to see me in my
office hours, said
he was doing a term
paper on something.
Could I give him
some references?
I said, great deal.
How about you come-- I will do
that-- how about you come down
to the study, and interview
some of the prisoners
and tell me how realistic
it is, because he
had been a prison chaplain
in a prison in Washington.
He comes down knowing it's an
experiment, and in two minutes,
he is the prison chaplain.
And what you see in the movie
is exactly what happened.
He introduces, I'm
Father [INAUDIBLE].
What's your name, son?
Almost every kid
said their number.
I'm 819.
I'm 216.
Then he says, what
are you in for?
And they say, what do you mean?
What is your charge?
And again, when we
had the police arrest,
the police always said one,
if a violation of penal code
459 PC, armed robbery,
breaking and entering.
They gave that.
And then he says, what
are you doing to get out?
I look at-- they say,
what do you mean, sir?
I don't understand.
And the words are exact.
You're in jail.
What are you doing to get out?
And again, he said, you're
a college student, right?
You need a lawyer.
You're in jail.
And I'm looking.
I'm saying, wow,
he's really into it.
And he says this to each kid.
So he--
KYLE ALVAREZ: It's
a different era too
where priests represented
something a little bit.
I mean this was pre-scandal.
PHILIP ZIMBARDO:
Pre-incest priest.
KYLE ALVAREZ:
Yeah, you want to--
and it was an interesting
thing, because even when
we were trying to
cast that part,
a lot of the actors who came
in played the nice priest.
And the one guy who came in and
understood that the scene was
really more that, that it was
not that he was a mean priest,
but he was like, what
are you here for?
What are you in for?
And it's that thing of like,
wait, you're this priest.
And then also the
next day, there
was a-- this isn't in
the film-- but there
was a lawyer who came
in who was-- somehow he
called a lawyer,
one of the kids.
And the lawyer, something
happened where--
PHILIP ZIMBARDO: No.
One of the kids said--
KYLE ALVAREZ: Oh, that's right.
PHILIP ZIMBARDO: One
of the kids said, I
have a cousin who's
a public defender.
He said, well, we
should get him.
He said, well, I don't
have his number here.
I'll call my mother.
So the kid gave the priest
his mother's number.
The priest called the mother.
The mother called
the public defender,
and in the real thing,
the public defender
came down on Friday.
And that's how I
ended this study.
And at that point--
KYLE ALVAREZ: But
even the lawyer
was using certain
vernacular of, hey, have you
done your parole hearing
yet, or let's start preparing
what you're going to do.
There was a certain thing,
where that's what we're saying.
The power of the role,
you give yourself
even just a little
bit of that ability
to be that, then you become it.
PHILIP ZIMBARDO:
Yeah, so I'm saying
we focus on the
prisoners and guards,
but I'm saying here's a priest,
here's a public defender,
here's me, here's a
seasoned ex-convict.
Everybody starts playing a role,
and that's really the message,
and you become the role.
In fact, in your
life, who are you?
I'm a teacher.
I'm an educator.
I'm a Google coder.
And then that's your job.
The job becomes your role,
and then it's your identity.
Say, who are you?
That's what you say.
MALE SPEAKER: Fascinating.
We'd love to turn it over to
you guys for some Q&A as well.
PHILIP ZIMBARDO: We want
to end with this after Q&A.
MALE SPEAKER: Absolutely.
We're going to.
AUDIENCE: My name's
Daniel Steinberg,
and with the experience of
40 years of understanding
of all this, it seems as
if Abu Ghraib should not
have been a tremendous
shock to those of us
who had followed any of this.
The question is, is it
possible and is there
any example of a prison in
which this kind of behavior
can be avoided?
Do any countries
have prisons where
they have a completely
different paradigm that works?
PHILIP ZIMBARDO: Yeah, so
most wonderful coincidence
is that President
Obama last week
visited a prison for the first
time in the history of America.
No president in
several hundred years
ever visited a prison,
meaning that whether or not
you're liberal or not, we are
paying millions of dollars
in taxes to maintain 2.3 million
American citizens in prison.
And hopefully, he
looks like he's
going to try to push
some prison reform.
Prisons are designed to punish.
They are not designed
to rehabilitate.
They're not designed to educate.
They're designed to punish.
Now when a jury or a judge
gives a prison sentence,
the only sentence is you
have lost your freedom
for this period of time, period.
It doesn't say, and
therefore, we're
going to humiliate
you, therefore, we're
going to put you in solitary
confinement. therefore,
we're going to punish you.
And the idea is you got all
these guys, many of whom
are uneducated, have an
opportunity to educate them.
They're going to be there two
years, three years, five years.
You can teach them coding.
You could teach them
all kinds of stuff,
and you could teach
them-- original prisons
were called penitentiaries,
meaning you have time
to think about the stuff you've
done and be penitent about it.
But it's been so transformed
into simply places
of punishment, where prisoners
come out mostly broken
and hate the system.
It turns out there's a prison--
it was in New York Times
a few weeks ago-- in Norway,
which trains the guards on how
to be compassionate,
trains the prisoners
on how to be-- accept
their role with dignity.
And apparently they
have like no recidivism.
I don't remember the name
of it, but it I know there's
a prison in Norway
that does what you say.
And clearly we need
just a new model.
We need a model--
the other thing
we should be concerned
about is the data
is that within three years
of being released, 60% to 70%
of all prisoners released
return on another crime,
in some cases, an
even more severe one.
That means-- that's the
definition of failure.
So you let somebody out, and
three years later, they're
doing the same or
worse thing again.
AUDIENCE: I'm
Melissa [INAUDIBLE],
intern actually at
Google this summer,
and actually a psychology
major, so this is pretty fun.
As a famous psychologist--
PHILIP ZIMBARDO:
Psychology major where?
AUDIENCE: At George Mason in DC.
PHILIP ZIMBARDO: OK,
yeah, of course, I know.
AUDIENCE: So how do you feel
about people associating you
essentially only with
Stanford Prison Experiment?
You've done lots
of other research
and lots of other really
interesting things.
PHILIP ZIMBARDO: Like what?
[LAUGHTER]
No, you're right.
I mean, it's just a
little demonstration
we did in six days, and
it one way, it's a curse.
So I never wrote
a book about it.
After I did this study,
I wrote a few articles.
It became famous
instantly because
of serendipitous circumstances.
The day after we did our
study on August 21, 1971,
there was an alleged escape
attempt of Soledad Brother
George Jackson from San
Quentin in which he was killed,
people say murdered
by the guards.
But before he was released,
all of his buddies
from solitary confinement, who
then killed all the informants,
killed some guards, and
prisons were in the news.
Three weeks later, Attica
prisoners revolted against--
took over the
prison, first time,
took over the whole
prison in sympathy
to George Jackson's murder.
And suddenly, there was a Senate
Judiciary Committee on crime,
and here I am knowing nothing
about prisons other than my
[INAUDIBLE], and I'm in
Washington, DC talking
about prison reform.
I'm in San Francisco talking
about juvenile justice.
But I should say--
you'll appreciate this--
so I'm sitting next
to the Superintendent
Mancuso of Attica, Warden
[INAUDIBLE] of San Quentin,
the head of the guard union,
the head of prisoners union.
I know nothing about
prison, so what do I do?
I say, would you mind if I
began by showing a slideshow
of the research we just did?
What that means is everybody
now shares the same visual,
and from then on, people said,
as we saw in Zimbardo's prison,
the guard role
dehumanizes prisoners.
Not in this
experiment-- they said,
as we saw in Zimbardo's--
so suddenly I had status I
didn't earn.
And people are
turning to me, why
do you think guards
dehumanize prisoners?
They're talking to me rather
than the superintendent, rather
than these other people.
So that was [INAUDIBLE].
So the main thing I did
right after the study is I
began to study the psychology
of shyness in adults.
Before that, psychologists
only studied shyness in kids,
so this is called
developmental psychologists.
Their cutoff point is 13.
Once you get to be 13,
then somebody [INAUDIBLE].
So it was as if when you're
13, you stop being shy.
No, nobody studied you.
So I studied shyness as a
self-imposed psychological
prison, where the
prison in you says,
here's a list of
things you can't do.
And the guards says what you
can, and the prisoner in you
says, OK, I deserve
the raise, but I
won't ask the boss for that.
I know the answer.
I won't-- I paid $10.
I know how to dance.
I won't ask the girl.
So essentially, you end
up saying, I'm worthless.
So I began to study shyness.
I had a shyness
seminar at Stanford.
I started doing
research on shyness
and discovered that to be not
shy is the rare exception.
In the universe, there's
not more than 5% to 10%
of people in any
country who are not shy.
So shyness, people
say I'm shy now.
I used to be shy, outgrow it.
I'm shy in situations.
It's the norm.
So we did research, and then I
started a clinic at Stanford,
and now it's in Palo Alto
University designed exclusively
to treat shyness, and we get
90% to 100% cure, because we
know exactly what causes it.
We know how to contain it.
We know how to treat it.
So that's what I'm most
proud of, because it's
an interesting idea.
We did research on it, and then
we ended up doing applied--
and then I wrote two books,
"Shyness- What It Is,
What to Do about It," and
"The Shy Child" that sold,
written for the general public.
So that's my legacy.
KYLE ALVAREZ: Well,
I definitely feel
a little-- I felt a little
burdened by that idea too,
knowing how much he'd done
outside this experiment.
And part of the thing
that when I came onboard,
I kind of had to
say, OK, we're only
making a movie about
these six days.
If you made a film called, "The
Doctor Philip Zimbardo Story,"
it would be wildly different.
This would be one portion of it.
And you have to
make that decision,
because you can't-- we could
only afford one sentence
on a title card at the end
of the film was really all we
could do to try to
encapsulate that feeling.
PHILIP ZIMBARDO: [INAUDIBLE].
I get a sentence.
KYLE ALVAREZ: Yeah,
and it's just one
of the challenges of
making it into a movie,
and you can only hope that
the movie leads people
to "The Lucifer Effect,"
that then leads people
to all these other things.
You can only hope for that or
engineer it to hopefully do
that, but you can't-- the
movie couldn't take on that
responsibility being called "The
Stanford Prison Experiment."
But it was definitely a
challenge to not include things
like that.
AUDIENCE: To what extent do you
think the finding of the study,
the experiment, can be
used as exculpatory excuse
for evildoers.
Like do you worry people
knowing that there
is this situational evil it
will affect their behavior?
PHILIP ZIMBARDO:
That's a good question.
So that's what
ties to Abu Ghraib.
When Abu Ghraib
happened in 2004,
somebody made a lot of
money releasing 12 images
that the soldiers had taken.
So these were army reservists.
They were not real soldiers,
and that's really key.
They were army reservists,
military police guards,
in the basement in Abu Ghraib
on the night shift, tier 1A.
It turns out they were 12
of more than 1,000 images.
Many of the images that were
not released are much worse.
And what happened was I had
a former Stanford student,
who was working at NPR, and I
happened to be in Washington.
He called me and said, hey,
Dr. Z, do you see those images?
I said, no.
He said, they're right
out of the prison study,
guards putting bags
over prisoners' heads,
stripping them naked,
and having them
simulate sexual activities.
Do you want to come
and talk about it?
So I did an interview the next
day at NPR, and I said look,
I know nothing about
that situation,
but there's enough similarity.
It looks like the Stanford
Prison Study on steroids,
because our study
went for six days.
This went for three months.
The abuses took place over
an extended period of three
months, and I said, I want to
believe American soldiers are
good apples, because remember,
the military and the Bush
administration, these
are a few rogue soldiers,
a few bad apples.
Whenever there's a scandal,
the system protects itself
by saying, don't blame us.
Blame them.
And I said, my concern is
somebody put our good apples
in really bad barrels.
So we want to
know, who did that?
And those are the
bad barrel makers.
So when we want to understand
any human behavior,
it's not enough to make a
dispositional individual now,
so we have to do a
situational analysis.
And then we have to
put the situation
in a systemic context.
So that's the first time I
used bad apples, bad barrels,
bad barrel makers.
And that took off.
So then I became
an expert witness
for the guard who should've
been in charge of the night
shift, Chip Frederick.
And in my testimony, I
said to the presiding
judge, Your Honor, Chip
Frederick is guilty as charged.
The fact that he did this
in this unique situation
does not change his
guilt or, innocence, so
the situation is
not excusiology,
but I can say with
all expert confidence
that he never would have
done that had he not
been put in that
situation, because I
studied his entire life from
the time he was born to now.
He's an outstanding soldier,
patriot, he won many awards,
and they put him
in this situation,
which is the most extreme
situation I could imagine.
I won't go through
all the details,
but you work 12-hour shifts.
When he finished his shift,
he slept in a prison cell
in a different
part of the prison,
because the prison
was under bombardment.
And also, the abuses happen
only on the night shift.
Nine of nine guards
on the night shift
did these things,
taking these pictures,
putting prisoners naked
in pyramids, et cetera.
None on the day shift,
how could that be?
So that's a situational
variable, zero of nine,
nine of nine.
It turns out the head
of military police--
I'm sorry-- the head of
military intelligence
goes to the head of military
police in Abu Ghraib and says,
we're not getting any
actionable intelligence.
We're interrogating
all these guys.
We're getting nothing.
And the military, the Bush
administration is on our ass.
The guys on your night shift
have to take the gloves off--
so you always use euphemism--
take the gloves off.
They have to break
the prisoners,
so when we interrogate them,
they'll spill the beans.
So essentially, you're
giving them total power.
In three months,
there's no evidence
that any senior officer ever
went down to the dungeon.
So you're telling them, do
what the fuck ever you want,
and nobody's going to
notice, except when
we interrogate them.
Hopefully, they're going
to give information.
And on the day shift,
senior officers
were there all the time.
So essentially, the
message there is power
without oversight, power
without surveillance
is a recipe for abuse.
So the worst abuse at
Stanford happened that night,
because sometime in the night--
I slept in my office upstairs,
so I never left the
situation for that week.
So that's a message.
You give people absolute
power, and without oversight,
without limits or without
constraints, over time,
that power will be abused.
And so my testimony reduced
the sentence from 15 years
to eight.
They were going to give
him 15 years, and the worst
that he did physically,
he hit a prisoner once,
but he allowed a lot of
the degrading images,
the degrading practices.
AUDIENCE: After you did the
Stanford Prison Experiment,
I'm wondering, did you reflect
on classic works of literature
like "Lord of the Flies"
and the similarities,
and what did you make of that?
PHILIP ZIMBARDO: I taught
"The Lord of the Flies."
I've written about it.
And it's a brilliant--
as Goulding
said it's a really brilliant
analysis of ordinary kids
put in a new situation, where
essentially, if you remember,
democracy takes over at first.
The good kid, the big kids
protect the little kids,
and then the message
is ultimately,
fascism rules,
authoritarians take over.
All you need is one or two.
And there's a dramatic
scene in the movie, where
one of the guys
strips himself naked
and then paints himself
with the colors,
and he gets the other guys
to change their appearance.
And at that point,
all hell breaks loose.
I actually did research
on deindividuation
following that,
meaning, what happens
when you make girls
feel anonymous,
and their job is to
shock other women--
I mean college students shock
the other women-- versus when
they feel identifiable.
They gave twice as
much electric shock,
held their finger down
on the shock button
twice as long when
they were anonymous.
So I did that study
before the prisoner study
based on "Lord of the Flies."
So again, good literature
taps into good psychology,
and what I try to do is
have good psychology map
onto good literature.
KYLE ALVAREZ: We
referenced that too
when we were shooting the film.
The last scene when this
character comes in and says
the experiment's over, we talked
a lot about their reaction.
It was a really
hard thing to get,
and the guys just
did it right, which
is sort of a sense of relief.
But we talked a lot about that.
What happens at the end when
they show up and they're saved,
they immediately
resort back to almost
like an infantile--
the way it's written,
they start like
crying and wailing,
and they even start acting
younger than their age.
And it's this interesting
thing of how quickly you
can fall down this
hole, and then
how quickly our
bodies get out of it
too is really-- In a weird
way, that's almost as alarming.
It bothers people
that, for instance,
at the end of the
film, none of them
suffered any long term abuse.
People don't want
to understand that.
All the reviews I read,
they're like, well, yeah, sure,
that's what the filmmakers
want us to believe.
And I said, well, no,
that's just the truth.
Many of them went on-- some went
on to be psychologists, prison
psychologists.
None of these guys were
known to be criminals
or had any kind of
institutionalization
or anything.
And so it's an
interesting thing,
and I remember talking to the
director of compliance, which
is a subject matter, which
is about the fast food hoax
that Dr. Zimbardo has
written about too.
And in his film,
we had on our side
the benefit of this
being much more famous.
So people were like, oh, people
know what really happened.
But after a compliance
period, people
were furious at him,
because they didn't
want to believe it was true.
And he was like, they were
mad at me, because they were
mad at the story in the movie.
So they were mad--
they couldn't accept
they were mad at the story,
so they were mad at the movie,
and then in turn were mad at me.
And you can't say,
well, it was real.
You can only say
so much to someone,
because they don't
want to believe it.
PHILIP ZIMBARDO: Yeah,
just very briefly,
I'm not sure how many people
know-- I think with compliance
was the wrong [INAUDIBLE].
So there was this
fast food hoax.
KYLE ALVAREZ: That was
the name of the film.
I don't know what the overall--
PHILIP ZIMBARDO: Yeah.
In 27 different states
in the United States,
some guy calls a
fast food restaurant,
all different kinds--
McDonald's, whatever--
and says, one of your
employees-- he says,
I'm Sergeant Johnson.
I'm Captain Johnson.
We have evidence that
one of your new employees
has been stealing,
has contraband.
We think it's related to drugs.
You need to send it down
to the police station,
or you can wait, and we'll
come and pick her up.
And they say, which one?
Well, the new one, the brunette.
Oh, Jenny?
Yeah, that's the one.
It's Jenny.
He's making this up.
He's in a phone booth.
And then what happens
is he said, well,
bring her to your security
area, and hold her there
for questioning.
And they do.
So now you have security
cameras are covering this,
and then he says, OK,
now while you're there,
why don't you begin?
So there's a female employee.
Strip her naked.
Do an initial search, and
tell us what you're doing.
And then in some
cases, the woman
says, well, I've got to
go back to the floor.
He said, well, do you have
anybody who could cover you?
Do you have a
husband, a boyfriend?
And she says, yeah,
I have my fiance.
He comes, and now
here's this guy
with a naked woman and the
guy who's a voyeur saying, OK,
now I want you to
follow my orders.
She may have something
under her breast,
so feel under her breast.
She may have
something in her anus.
So this poor girl,
18-year-old girl,
he's now doing
this sexual stuff,
and then finally ends up, OK,
we still think she's guilty,
so I want to punish her.
So make her have
oral sex on you.
It's all caught on
the security camera.
And he was finally caught by
really good detective work,
but it's not one guy.
I mean, it's one guy, but
it's 27 different places,
and everybody who
sees the film blames
the woman in the film who
was the security manager.
And she just says, he
was really convincing.
I was following orders like
I do as a low level employee.
At McDonald's, we follow orders.
People say do this stuff.
And nobody wanted to believe it.
So they were angry
at the filmmaker.
They were angry at this woman.
No, the guy you've got to
be angry at is this guy.
KYLE ALVAREZ: Yeah,
the creepy guy.
PHILIP ZIMBARDO: He actually
got off, because from the time
he was arrested,
these things stopped.
But there was only
circumstantial evidence.
The good news is the
young woman who was abused
got a big court settlement.
MALE SPEAKER: And that's
actually a perfect transition.
I promise I'd end with
one final question,
and I'll ask it to you both,
but in a different way.
I'll let you guys decide.
So for you, I'll
ask both of you,
but for you, it's
the classic, what
do you want people to
take away from the film?
And what I'll address
similarly to Dr. Zimbardo
really quickly is the way this
came up was before we sat down.
I told Dr. Zimbardo
that whenever
Kitty Genovese come up, this
trial Milgram's experiment
comes up.
I am that guy in the room that
says, no, I wouldn't do it.
I wouldn't have done that.
I wouldn't have gone that far.
I would've helped
the person in need.
I would not have let the
situation affect who I am.
I'm always that guy in the room.
And so the question
there as well,
you talked about the hero
training that you're doing.
It almost surprises
me what you just
said that you should blame
the guy in the phone booth
exclusively.
Is it not also on those of us in
society to stand by our morals
and risk public
ridicule to do what
we think is the right thing?
That's my ending question there.
KYLE ALVAREZ: To take away
from the film, honestly,
I had one goal, which
is just conversation.
I didn't want the
movie to tell you what
you should be talking about.
The experiment's still
relevant 44 years later,
and it's relevant, because
it's always relevant.
So I didn't want the movie
to narrow that in or say,
oh, look at what
happened at Abu Ghraib,
or I didn't want
to contextualize it
in our history, because I
wanted the movie to sort of be
able to exist always.
And so for me, it's just if
it leads to conversation,
then it's great.
To me, that was the
number one goal.
Or I should say fruitful
conversation, obviously.
I mean it leads to
saying, I fucking hated
that movie, that's not
a conversation you want.
But for me, it was,
and that's the goal
that I just don't want to
ever make a movie that you
forget 10 minutes later.
MALE SPEAKER: Wonderful.
KYLE ALVAREZ: And in this
case, hopefully people
look up the experiment,
and it leads them
to more understanding.
MALE SPEAKER: Absolutely.
I think we all did.
Thank you.
PHILIP ZIMBARDO: Prisonexp.org
is a great website
that I've been involved
with for like 20 years,
and we've just redone it.
And it everything there is
about the prison study, prisons,
et cetera.
And so what I would like
to take away is the flip.
So here, I created evil.
See, criminologists,
sociologists,
study evil from the outside in,
and they interview criminals.
You visit prisons.
I wanted to create
evil from inside
out that has put good people in
a bad place and say, who wins?
If you have a bad place
filled with good people,
shouldn't they dominate?
Or if the bad place is
really bad and evil,
doesn't the place win
and humanity lose?
And unfortunately,
that's the conclusion.
And in this study, in the
movie, there are no heroes,
except the woman who challenges
me, confronts me to say,
what you're doing is wrong,
that these are not prisoners,
they're not guards, they're
boys, and they're suffering,
and it's your fault. And
in the real experiment,
she then says-- we had
just moved in, it shows,
which is true at the
beginning of the movie.
She says, if this
is the real you,
I don't want to continue
my relationship.
We had just moved in.
We were planning to get married.
And so that's her own.
She's willing to give up
a romantic relationship,
a marital relationship for a
moral principle about kids she
doesn't even though, but
she saw the suffering.
So for me, that's really heroic.
So a hero is somebody who comes
to the aid of others in need
and/or defends a moral cause
aware that there's cost.
So altruism is heroism light.
You give money to the church.
It doesn't cost you.
So heroes are rare,
only because people
in weighing the situation
say it's not worth it.
So whistleblowers
are proactive heroes.
You see fraud, you
see corruption.
You have to collect data.
Often, you have to get
people on your side.
Most heroes are
really more impetuous.
You react to the situation
like the famous hero
in New York, the subway hero.
A guy falls on the tracks.
He jumps on the
railroad track, puts
the guy between the tracks
as the train goes over them.
For half an inch, he would've
been a dumb, dead hero.
It would've cut his head off.
So essentially, when
we finish this study--
when I started writing "Lucifer
Effect," I realized that I know
nothing about heroes, because
I started the last chapters,
how do you resist
these powerful forces?
In all the research,
in all the studies
of evil in the real world in the
Holocaust, in Bosnia, Rwanda,
there's always a small
percentage, 5%, 10%,
never more than 30% of
people who do what-- resist.
I won't go along.
They don't go along.
In some cases, they not
only don't go along.
They challenge the evil.
And I said, you know, I don't
know anything about heroes.
I never thought about
it, and I should
have given this woman
who challenged me,
and we've been
married for 44 years.
So I began to do research,
library research on heroes.
Turns out the word
hero and heroism
does not exist in any
psychology textbook.
It's not part of the
positive psychology movement,
because compassion and
empathy are virtues.
Heroism is a civic action.
So essentially, I begin to
say, hey, wait a minute.
What good is
compassion and action
if it doesn't lead to
action, because action
is what changes the world?
So I started seven years
ago in San Francisco
a nonprofit called the
Heroic Imagination Project.
The simple goal is to teach
people, all people, especially
young people, to learn how to
express the inner hero that you
all have, especially as kids.
We really had this inner hero.
Not through superheroes,
which is dramatic,
but the wrong direction,
because superheroes
don't have the most
important thing in the world
that every kid has is a brain.
They are the creation of
somebody with a creative brain.
So we say, you have
something they don't have,
and with your brain you
could create anything.
So essentially, we're
going to teach you
how to be a wise and
effective hero, how
to analyze social
situations, how
to take wise and
effective action,
but the point is we want to
inspire you to always take
the right action.
Stand up, speak out in
challenging situations
starting in your family, in
your school, in your community.
And then we have a
training program.
We teach people how to do this,
and then the other thing we do
is I started a
revolution in education.
We have a number of lessons
about the bystander effect,
about-- I know Carol Dweck was
here from Stanford last week.
How do you transform
a fixed mindset,
which is to say I'm good or
not good at this, to a growth
mindset?
I'm good at anything if I put
in enough practice and effort.
How to reverse
prejudice, how to change
groups that have negative
influence to positive,
so we call this
understanding human nature,
and we have six
of these programs.
We hope to have four
more on conservation
and sustainability.
But what's revolutionary
is teachers don't teach.
We give them a script,
and all the programs
organize around powerful
videos, because kids
live in a visual world.
We show a video, and instead
of having a class discussion,
the teacher has pairs,
pairs or triads.
And we try to have a
boy and a girl together,
because boys never
answer in class.
Girls always do.
And so essentially,
you show the video
of a failure of a
bystander, and then you say,
what were the people thinking?
Why didn't they help?
What would you do?
What's the difference between
looking in at a situation
and being in?
Then we show them the
Kitty Genovese video,
and we say, how does
anybody study this?
Then we show them video
of social psychologists
study this.
And then we say,
when should you help?
When should you not help?
And then think of a
time when you helped.
Think of a time when
you didn't help.
And then we go through, so
each of the six programs
has the same eight activities.
So once the teacher learns to
do one, it's easy to transfer.
And then the key is at the end,
you say, OK, spread the word.
That's activity eight.
What does that mean?
What's the most interesting
thing you learned today?
And the kid writes it.
Now tell somebody.
They write it down.
Tell your mother, your cousin,
your bus driver, the grocery
man, and then the next week
says, what did your mother say?
My mother couldn't believe it.
How could it be that when
there's a lot of people around,
nobody helps?
It's better to have just one.
Now go back.
Ask your mother if she
could tell one other person.
So now this little lesson, which
we now have in remote areas
in Hungary.
Some mother is telling the
butcher about the bystander
effect.
So in that sense, it's really
a revolution in education.
And the problem we have
is we started here.
We cannot get our program in
any San Francisco high school,
because the high schools,
they say, if it's not STEM,
it's not preparing for the
exams, we can't work it in.
So our program is all over
Hungary, it's all over Poland,
it's in Corleone, the
Godfather town in Sicily,
and so right now we're
trying to-- we just applied
for a Google community
grant, because I
have virtually no staff.
But we have a hero
factory in my basement.
We're creating these
little, little heroes.
So we need a staff.
We need sophisticated help
to move it to the next level.
So we have the material.
We have the desire
and the inspiration.
MALE SPEAKER: Wonderful.
Well, thank you both.
PHILIP ZIMBARDO:
Thank you so much.
MALE SPEAKER: Great to see you.
[APPLAUSE]